You're listening to radio lab
from New York public radio,
public radio W and Y C o n n p,
ah,
are live at the Fitzgerald
Theater and shape.
Paul, Minnesota.
October 30th, 1938
on that night,
the United States experienced a kind
of mass hysteria the we'd never seen
before.
And the reason which today sounds
almost comical was a radio play
tell me I did say to him was that Orson
wells and the mercury set her on the air
and the water of the world.
[inaudible]
around 12 million people were
listening. Most got the joke.
It was Halloween after all.
But if you consider that about one out
of every 12 people didn't get the joke.
That's what surveys found afterwards
about one out of every 12 people who heard
the broadcast thought it was true and
that some percentage of that 1 million
people ran out of their homes, towels
over their faces, clutching children,
tripping, breaking limbs will.
That constitutes a major freak out.
[inaudible] and in this,
our first ever live hour on
radio lab here at Saint Paul,
Minnesota at the Fitzgerald
Theater. We ask why,
why do people panic? And of course
we'll ask the big question as well,
which is Canaan happened again.
I'm Jad I've been rod,
thank you all for coming in.
Where is my coat?
So let me, let me just say at the outset,
I'm just a tiny bit of puzzle
before you do it, just tell it.
Tell everyone who you
are. I, yeah, I'm Robert.
Can you just say Robert Krulwich,
which is my name. And uh, uh,
with all due respect,
I mean if we had any number of things
we could have done in the hour and could
have done sex lives of watermelons
or something interesting about
chrysanthemums,
I don't know why choose a Martian
invasion radio show from 1938 old,
old, old. I'm thinking, I can't believe
you wait till now to ask me a question.
I'm just thinking. So some of them
might be thinking, you know, old, old,
no, I'm gay. Well, I guess it's a
valid question you ask. Truth is,
I actually only discovered the war of the
worlds recently in a 2001 kind of late
2001 actually not long after that day
in 2001 and it just really struck me and
it wasn't so much that the broadcast had
a kind of end of the World Nis that I
guess we were all feeling
in real life at that moment,
but it was more just the way that the,
the story unfolded step by step by step
and how in the broadcast you feel like
you were lost inside a newscast, which
is not unlike what it was like. Yeah,
we were all glued to the TV and real
life grasping at these pieces of news,
trying to figure out what was
going on. And that was very much,
I think what they were trying to
create in the broadcast. But now,
many years later, what I'm really
left with is a question, what?
Well,
if I were alive in 1938 in front of
the radio and I heard this sounds,
what would I have thought would I have
believed it would have not believed?
I mean, I don't know. What about you? I
don't really know. I don't really know.
I Dunno. Okay, let's do
something. Just start us off here.
Let's actually go back to 1938 and see
if we can figure out how these sounds
landed on people's ears and what
information they had in their heads. So,
and I need your help with this.
How would I help with that?
I want you to go over to that
seat right there. That's,
we're going to call that seat in
1938 all right. There Nike. Okay.
Now just, let's just all imagine
there you are on your easy chair.
You're maybe drinking a cream soda.
Let's tune the dial. Okay.
Trying to find something here.
[inaudible]
Raymond Ruck. Hello, who is Rick Mark,
you know a Raymond ruck. Hello.
The thoughts of the Fetish Raymont
recolor lead dog with lower cupboard.
You don't know that there's no
such person as Ramon Rick. Hello.
And that it's just a record in a CBS
studio, but it sounds professional enough.
So you sit back, you relax. But then later
we're not.
We're telling you to the music of Ramrod
Kelo playing for you in the Meridian
Room or the Park Plaza Hotel
situated in downtown New York.
So at this point you think
I'm thinking explosions on Mars,
hydrogen gas moving towards earth.
A little strange,
but how could it be so bad if I still get
to listen to the fabulous nodes at the
lovely Raymond that color
and he does continue to play
for another minute, 34 seconds.
But then it happens again. Ladies
and gentleman following on the news,
given an odd bullet in the moment of golf,
the government media or logical
bureau has requested the Lord.
No. Before we go any further there
for, are we going to get further?
Let me ask a really basic question
here. I mean, we're dealing with a play,
a radio play. Yeah.
Why would Orson wells in his posse of of
troubadours start their play this way?
The original hg wells story was written
in 1898 so it was really an old book at
the time. And there, there is no reporter
character in the book. By the way,
does everybody know this word? The
world story. And most people do.
The story basically is this little green
creatures from Mars for a number of
reasons having to do
with thirst or something,
have to leave their planet and they come
to Earth. They're not very nice people.
They invade, they destroy
quite a number of us.
And then ironically in the end
they get killed by little viruses,
our smallest inhabitants of our
planet, bite them and destroy them.
And it's science fiction of course.
But in 1938 most kids knew this story.
It was very popular. So I don't see why.
Right? And in fact,
let me bring in a clip from a Orson wells
producer at the time, John Houseman,
uh, Austin and I chose it.
We decided the time had come,
we should be doing a science fiction
show. I'm so, we tried a few of that one.
Very easy to do,
do in just a few days before they
had to be on the air with their next
installment.
John Houseman pulls that book off the
shelf to shows it to o w says, Hey,
what about this? And
Orson Welles says this,
you want me to do this?
Well, he, uh, had trouble in what
sense? In the sense of the design,
you said it was dough. No,
he told it he was boring. Uh,
if it was something that
happened 50 years ago,
everybody knows it didn't happen.
So, uh, who the hell care, right?
If we're going to make people
care about this old story,
we've got updated not 18, 98 and 1938.
And it just so happened
that one month prior,
something had happened that
forever changed the world.
Ban The news. The wall was that
we'll begin with the, this,
the, my, my
[inaudible] [inaudible]
Hitler was threatening
Europe first, Austria,
then Czechoslovakia World War Two was
right around the corner and cvs sent a
team of guys to cover
the story among them.
Columbia continues with expensive
coverage of the European cartoons
and in September,
Moreau and his CBS producers did something
with the news that was kind of novel.
The broke in.
We interrupt this program of music by
Harry James and his orchestra to bring you
a bullet in just received.
And the w o r new is wrong.
No, this had happened before but never
quite liked this with live reports,
eye witness accounts,
and never quite so much
square up in broadcast and bring it up
in part in the [inaudible] night of prep
in just one month. These bulletins
have become so numerous. Yeah,
interrupt our program to
bring you a special broadcast.
That bulletins were practically
interrupting bulletin.
We interrupted program to bring
you with Special Brighton guys.
We interrupt this broadcast and to bring
her this important bulletin from the
United
we interrupt this program to
take you to the NBC News Room.
Here is a special [inaudible] on the NBC.
So after weeks and weeks of hearing
these constant interruptions,
it's easy to understand
why this [inaudible]
the gentleman following on the news given
an odd bullet in the moment of goal,
didn't sound like a play,
but government media a lot.
We have arranged an interview with
another astronomer, Professor Pierson.
I don't know whether I need
anymore. Raymond. Marcelo,
I need to know a little more
about this Martian, uh, thing.
Just seeing how slowly it
starts. And by the way, um,
what time do you got on your, uh,
your, uh, fucker watch their, uh,
the pocket watch says eight
Oh four, eight oh four.
Tell me when it gets to eight oh
five to what? Eight oh five to eight.
Oh five, eight oh five.
You know, just let me know.
[inaudible] no. Okay. It'll five.
This is my favorite minute
in understanding one of the
greatest media hoaxes of
all times. Cause the thing that's
interesting is that at this moment in, uh,
October of 1938, art,
Orson wills and the mercury theater
of the air were not that popular.
They had a tiny, tiny
slice of the audience.
And so not too many people were
listening. Certainly not at the beginning.
From eight o'clock to eight Oh four and
so not too many people heard this very
important introduction,
the Columbia Broadcasting System
and the affiliated station.
Was that the war of
the world by h g wells?
Well, what, wait, why
didn't they hear that? Well,
cause at that very same moment,
the majority of people
listening were tuned into this
[inaudible]
the makers of Jason Sad barn copied is
the power of Glam. You know, it's fresh.
Resent the chase in San Bono,
um, that chase and Sandborne hour. Now
that that was good. That was Ed Bergen.
It had the puppet Charlie McCarthy
who, who, who liked girls. It was,
this was rainy. It was the most popular
show at the time, right opposite
three. Theater Theater
had 10 times the audience.
But at eight oh five host Don Ameche
introduces and not so popular singer
and it's the rousing rip roaring
song of Vagabond from the Vagabond J.
Aw, you're the Megan [inaudible].
And yesterday moment, thousands, hundreds.
We don't know how many
listeners started to dial surf.
Where are they landed on the mercury
theater of the air already in progress
where they stayed.
We are ready now to take your to the
principle observatory at Princeton
because by then a
strange meteor had landed
where Carl Phillips, our commentator
will interview Professor Richard Pearson,
famous astronomer. That's it.
The IB cannot question at any
time but better. No Piping.
Typically Mr Product Guy cannot
account for it. I just know.
Yeah,
we've had four interruptions now at this
point you've called your whole family
into the room.
Marge on media is on Mars, March.
Meteors what meteors on Mars
and just as you are utterly confused.
Along comes the expert, you know,
people surveyed afterwards said,
I didn't believe this thing.
I thought it was all baloney until I heard
that government official guy or the a
Princeton professor and this script
is chocked full of believable experts.
Great. Or
the Natural History Museum
Professor Endoscopists of
the California Astronomical
Society. There are General
Montgomery Smith, Capitan,
Lansing of the signal card.
Maybe subconsciously that had an effect
to convince people that something was in
fact happening.
A feeling furthered a moment
later when the professor and uh,
the reporter Carl Phillips go live
to that field in Grovers mill,
New Jersey with that media,
right. Or whatever it is.
It's landed metal casing is definitely,
yeah. Great. The mouth, that's
kind of be shape. What's the lie,
but dripping sweat. I hate
reenlist lips. Actually
now before we get too far into this,
see, let me play you a another clip,
right? You're providing majestically
Prada like them. Great. Better,
no doubt. [inaudible] a little bit more
lining the windows. Looking
down the road ahead of him.
[inaudible] it's my editor. Oh
my. Get out of the way, please.
If Bernie bursting into flames and
it's falling on the mornings, that
all the humanity and
all the Freebie garage,
this is tape of the Hindenburg crash.
Sure. It's still fresh in people's minds.
Happened one year before the broadcast,
before going on the air that night after
Frank Reddick who played that reporter,
Carl Phillips in the field,
he went to the library,
dug up this old tape or not so
old and played it to himself.
Oh,
the humanity and all the managing
all the humanity and all that bad,
maybe karate of the humanity
and all that faceted. Maybe
get himself in the right frame of mind
for that now famous attack scene in that
field in New Jersey,
the transmission cuts off.
Okay.
12 million people have just
heard slithery green aliens.
He visceral policemen, farmers
and reporters followed by
nothing.
Ladies and gentlemen, due to
circumstances beyond our control,
we are unable to continue the
broadcast from Grovers mill.
Evidently there is some difficulty
with our field transmission. However,
we will return to that point
at the earliest opportunity
and when they do return,
what you learn is that that grounded
flying saucer that just zapped all those
men has now stood up. It's grown legs,
it's as tall as a tree and it is marching
through the countryside,
stopping everything in its path.
And then we are taken to
field reports, bleive battles,
scenes between militia and paws. But
before we do, let me play one more clip.
This one is real.
If you ran and one of the
areas you mentioned or like
a child of school age and
where did you have an evacuated,
you should send him to school tomorrow
Friday with hand luggage containing the
child's gas mask, a
change of under clothing.
This is Edward r Murrow reporting
from London. Same time period.
Just to give you a sense of how scary it
was to be alive at this moment in time,
kids in England were being told
to take gas masks to school,
all of which would have made the
following dramatize battle scenes.
Thank you. Now to the field
headquarters of the state military,
there's Broberg now New Jersey,
all the more real
37 degree up
here. The New Jersey militia
fire on a fleet of marsh and pods
to no avail.
Their sales bounce right off in the
Martians in retaliation release a cloud of
poisonous gas, which slowly
overtake the soldiers
he meet us. He touched you.
[inaudible]
ladies and gentlemen,
I have a grave announcement to
make incredible as it may seem,
both the observations of science and
the evidence of our eyes lead to the
inescapable assumption that that was
strange beings who landed in the Jersey
farmland tonight are the vanguard of
an invading army from the planet Mars.
The Battle of which took place tonight
at Grove of mills has ended in one of the
most stopping the feet ever
suffered by an army in modern times.
7,000 men armed with rifles and machine
gun pit it against the single fighting
machine of the invaders
from Mile 129 survivors.
One moment please. Ladies and gentleman
now the Bolton from Langenfeld,
Virginia.
The monster is not in control of the
Middle Section of New Jersey and has
effectively cut the state through its
center highways to the north, south,
and West. The clot with
frantic human track lease,
not army reserves are unable to control
the med flight communication lines are
down from Pennsylvania
to the radio tracks.
The tone and service just continue
to prevail throughout New Jersey.
In eastern Pennsylvania. The Bolton
cutting planes report enemy machines.
Now three numbers increasing speed north
when kicking over house at the same
time we take you to Washington,
hit the sun was up a nation,
the secretary of the interior,
I shall not try to conceal the
gravitate bullet in it handed me.
Pick your way from the
doctrine. Doesn't do that
with a cup at the end
now, no more defense.
Everything wiped out.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we don't know exactly how many people
panic that night. Here's what we do now.
The Trenton Police Department got
2000 calls in under two hours.
The New York Times switchboard received
875 calls alone from people wanting to
know where they'd be safer
on the roof or in the gas
rate shelter in the cellar.
We're lucky we do have transcripts of
what happened on the other side of radios
that night.
Thanks to a Princeton sociologist who
went out and conducted a series of
interviews after the broadcast and
what's amazing is how effective that
broadcast was.
Some listeners said they actually
felt like they were choking.
Others reported to police that
they saw with their own eyes.
As they looked at the Manhattan skyline,
they saw a thin veil of smoke
from the battle over the city.
Some said they saw marsh and machine's
high stepping their way down the palace
aide, splash, splash,
splash. Uh, and many people,
when they called operators or
police, they didn't say, oh my God,
we're being invaded by
Martians. They said, oh my God,
we're being invaded by Germans.
Here are some of the
literal transcriptions.
This is what real people
actually said. Everybody ready?
I knew it was some Germans
trying to gas us all,
but when the announcer kept on
calling them people from Mars,
I just thought he was ignorant.
I immediately called up the Maplewood
police and asked if there was anything
wrong. They answered, we
know as much as you do,
keep your radio tuned in and
follow the announcer's advice.
I called into my husband, Dan,
why don't you get dressed?
You don't want to die
in your working clothes.
I looked in his box and saw some chicken
left from Sunday dinner that I was
saving for Monday night
dinner, said to my nephew,
we may as well eat this chicken.
We walked in here in the morning.
This is Austin Wells,
ladies and gentlemen,
out of character to assure you that
the war of the world has no further
significant and at the holiday
offering it was intended to be.
We are not related the world before
your very ears and utterly destroyed the
CBS. You will be relieved.
I hope to learn that we didn't mean it
and that both institutions are still open
for business.
That was how Orson wells concluded the
war of the worlds broadcast with those
words. Basically it was a joke. Gotcha.
But it was only after he and his producer
John has been left and read the papers
the next day and they understood
just how much trouble they had caused
[inaudible] because of for at least a
couple of hours we believe we were mass
murder.
Extremely surprised to learn that I story,
which is become familiar to children
through the medium of comic strips and a
this as well as in the press
conference. That following day,
mini succeeding novels and adventure
stories should have had such an immediate
and profound effect upon radio listeners.
So immediate and so profound that
the FCC Commissioner of the time,
George Henry Payne, labeled
the Mercury theater of the air,
get this terrorists
[inaudible]
radio terrorists.
But there is one thing we must not overlap
all this took place in 1938 and our
less sophisticated yesterday that did not
know the atom bomb guided missiles and
rockets that may shortly
fly to the Moon Edward
r Murrow in 1957 was he
correct when he said that?
Where are we really so
on sophisticated in 1938
I mean, it's so different
from now. Well, let's see.
Stay with US folks. I'm Robert
Krulwich and Jana boom rod.
We're alive at the Fitzgerald
Theater in Saint Paul,
Minnesota radio lab will continue.
Just a moment [inaudible].